Flavor that I didn't find any other
grand.
Try Camels and see
and point at the first men came to
western.
Mine had this invention where he's
actually almost.
It was like mythical or something,
but anyway,
it was this chamber under ground where
you could go and hear everything that
anyone had ever said about you behind
your back,
but in order to get to the best thing
which was at the like the lower most
chamber,
you had to start at the worst insult and
work your way down.
My friend always used to say he could
never make it two steps,
but I don't know.
I think I could make it to the bottom.
Maybe that's because I have a poor
imagination.
Do you guys have.
It is simply not pleasant to be
objectively observed.
It's like seeing a candid photo of
yourself online,
not smiling or posing,
but simply looking the way you will
apparently always do oblivious and Bush
face with your mouth open.
It's proof that we are visible to others
that we are seeing in all are naked
silliness and stupid.
A group of friends.
I think it's inevitable you're going to
spend time talking with one another
about one another behind one another's
backs and it's not always going to be
nice thing,
but I think it can be healthy.
Your friends are never going to be so
perfect that they don't act like an
idiot sometimes or repeat their own
mistakes or do other things which are so
clearly against their interests and I
think it's healthy to vent to other
mutual friends about how aggravating and
crazy this person can be if for nothing,
but to ensure that in this instance,
the crazy one isn't you.
First of all,
brands don't talk behind your back.
So one thing is when people talk behind
your back,
it really shows you what kind of
friendly.
Our first thing to remember is that if
anyone talks behind your back,
they're probably doing because they're
jealous.
Other day at lunch,
I was part of a whole group of
colleagues,
colleagues in my school and who were
talking behind our bosses back.
I mean like,
seriously.
It just is like isn't necessary.
It's not.
It's not necessary.
We're talking behind someone's back.
Ken,
just be plain Shitty,
especially when you're trying to gain
the favor of one friend at the expense
of another,
these purely negative gossip or the
kinds of talk that we should try our
best to avoid and speak up against when
we hear it began.
As kreider says,
the operative fallacy here is that we
believe that unconditional love means
not seeing anything negative about
someone,
but usually the fact that friends talk
behind other friends backs is precisely
because they have a stake in the
friendship and spend a lot of time
thinking about this person whom they
love.
Talking with friends about friends like
talking with friends is the important
work of French.
Just like telling a friend that you love
them is as important as telling another
friend that you told your friend that
you love them.
So much of what we tell others is what
we want for ourselves.
Does it have to be as circuitous as
this?
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
This is great.
Oh,
that friend who his name is Jake.
Just a friend of mine.
He's a great guy.
Learn your instruments.
You want me to dance as well?
It's a beautiful dance for them.
For the electric guitar lesson.